ho la febbre di mortacci mia limor
limonta c mia ho la febbre e va beh
chissenefrega dello stato di salute
degli youtubers ciao amici buongiorno
buongiorno un caso sono le nove come
state tutto bene ho la febbre orribile
orribile avere la febbre
vabbè vabbè perché altro sono malati ci
simo sono malati di questa era e un alta
in questa stanza fa caldo quindi non
serve averla in realtà però è per per
creare più ambiance da malati capito e
un periodo un po di merda perché fa
piove fa freddo e le cose quindi io sono
in facilmente influenzabile sicily
cagionevole così non capisco youtube o
quasi morendo
cliccate moglie in diretta questo è il
click day il classico kickback sono
contento mi state bene
oggi vorrei andare avanti ancora con le
isole shaun dobbiamo finirlo siamo più o
meno a metà
l'ultima volta sono stato fermo 6 ore
ringraziando gesù cristo oggi non faremo
la stessa cosa
opera finito di mangiare tra l'altro
mini fantastico e niente alla causa
dell'articolo 13 no in realtà mi sono
arrivati un po di messaggi mi hanno
detto che è stato approvato però nessuno
mi ha detto niente quindi secondo me non
non stiamo parlando ancora di sé
della roba cazzuta dice nel senso stiamo
parlando di un'approvazione poi come
viene definito magari cambia ancora
qualcosa quindi non è detto non so
neanche se fosse stato approvato o meno
ho letto un paio di messaggi che mi sono
arrivati in direct quindi quelle quella
la mia fonte per farvi capire quanto ne
so comunque nessuno sia allarmato quindi
non penso sia niente di grave per adesso
tanto sono robe che andranno fino a fine
anno credo non succederà niente di
strano
credo grazie max grazie ragazzi cos'è ti
adoro sei fantastico di seconda quando
proprio canale grazie max grazie fabio
the game
hai risposto a ciccio no e più avanti
per ne parleremo di sta roba tranquillo
sciopero ti seguo da quando facevi io
sud lander me dal 2013 grazie anche
grazie fabio grazie al b grazie max
gazzé francesco e atlas lander man c'è
proprio da quando ero sano poi sono
diventato malato
vabbè allora ragazzo genio avanti con
alison scusatemi se mi sposto dovevo
mettere il volume di là si è fatto un
paio di chiari io faccio sempre poi di
chiacchiere all'inizio perché ho
piazzola intro o faccio un paio di
chiacchiere dipende come univa la
giornata sono non gradire piazza la
intro questa qua e vi metto le canzoni
di sottofondo così almeno mi intrattengo
tipo aboliva che qualora però oggi avevo
qualcosa lire non l'ho fatto dipende
come mi gira ciao francesco grazie mille
allora partiamo with arjen isola in
scena voi non avete idea questa
settimana stanno per uscire dei video
madonna non avete idea non vedo l'ora
che ci sia sta settimana magari se mi
faccia anche la febbre ce la vediamo un
pò easy guarisci presto grazie grazie no
vabbè ma non ciola lembo la sola
la l'influenza norma di fi grazie milan
grazie ma non alle grazie
iniziamo dai che sono partito troppo
tardi l'ultimo l'ultimo episodio suscita
afferrava a svegliare se vi ricordate
l'androide ci ho messo 6 anni poi ho
capito che in realtà il tasto per
svegliarla era di fianco vabbè vabbè e
ho anche capito che voi non siete
attendibili per dare consigli quindi mi
devo guardare i tutorial ci totali walk
through grazie paolo grazie quel tony
grazie martina grazie andrea le slot ciò
claudio vela fa vie bel video con
launchpad grazie zio ne apprezzo tra
l'altro fai perché ce l'hai con cicero
non ce l'ho con ciccio ma figurati è
semplicemente che lui ha tirato una
frecciatina e io gli ho tirato proprio
la freccia di katniss everdeen
scaramucce scava come si dice sono
pagati nei se questi soldi singh per
favore
comunque più avanti continueremo questa
storia c'è il gossip tanto a voi via
avrebbe piacere gossip gossip
il gossip sembrava mia nonna quando deve
fare inglesismi ciao giulia ciao
francesco ciao max grazie mille sei
pazzo si ama si è svegliato il bronzo
zio ha sì sì oca avevo già preso il
prezzo che io che devo portare il prezzo
all'inizio quindi dove ero partito ciao
giulia ciao alla tunica bianca vela farr
i cani ci portare kingdom hearts
volentieri c'è solo un problema di fondo
e questa cosa non vi piacerà kingdom
hearts
io non l'ho mai giocato
è una cosa bruttissima da dire lo so
però ci sono un sacco di giochi
nell'infanzia noi non posso averli
toccati tutti e kingdom hearts uno di
quei pochi anche spylo ad esempio non ho
mai giocato
ciò queste lacune d'infanzia mi piace ai
ragazzi se non muoio allora sono io che
ho la febbre o se gioco ha fatto un po
col culo
secondo me sono io che ho la febbre
oppure wingardh di un leviosa facciamo
lo so sei stato tu a fare la magia qua
se bravissimo sei un mago harry
ciao super tia ciao alessio l'avessimo
gentilissimi un bacio voi spero sia
qualche c'è quello a fare lì che
lampeggia scassato che da tre episodi
che sta lei quindi spero mica sarà
aperto il condotto mi sto calando in
mano era solo il condotto mi dite come
si sente se è tutto a posto che sono
risolvo sostituisci andiamo più nascosta
di quelle ma ricorda tutta la vita
e invece de france per salvare la
partita ma vabbè dai tanto di sempre
vabbè dato non mi corona che sinistro
punto c'era alien o chi sei grazie della
buona fortuna con ania in un bacio a te
diciamo e ringrazi mille all'ora che
doveva fare qua l'unico l'obiettivo
passata da six sinestesie perché
cerchiamo per costante di una navetta
percorso alternativo alla navetta dove
lasciato solo se è vero che ha dovuto
andare da samuel taylor chiaro che si
era scassato tutto era esploso tutto
trovi uscito per limite devo passare
dall impianto fluidi sintetici
oddio sembra sembrare mostrasse company
uguale sono le porte dove entra niente
ci sono i mostri uguale a forse seguire
vabbè che spara c'è gente che c'ha le
armi state calma abbiamo visto se non mi
hanno visto posso provare ad ammazzarli
alla distanza perché ci prova ma uno
l'ho preso stanno lì fermi gli spari
stanno fermi va bene ma va tranquillo è
cosa stai ferma un attimo finiti colpi
disse che scarso e poi a forte ma che mi
volete far giocare a me ne scopia agente
fermo
e daje e schiatta otto corpi per far
fuori due persone bene hanno creato le
collezioni con tutti i giochi di
masterizzati di ps4 digos di kingdom
hearts iii lo so so sto rumore e il mio
telefono a noi il mio telefono pensavo
fosse l'allarme che non ci sono
non mi toccano grazie pensavo fosse per
me è morto
no è ancora in circolazione esatto ciao
amici a posto ho sprecato otto colpi di
revolver per ammazzarvi pro grazie a dio
ce li hai nel corpo mi riprendo ciao a
tutti nel corpo veramente le riprese 8
regala ripreso tutti gli altri colpi sto
male va bene così quando amarsi la gente
poi vai a togliergli proiettili che gli
annunci ho sempre pensato questa cosa
devo andare di qua c'è niente faceva
vedo un condotto quindi immagino ci sia
della roba qui questa roba qua allora
niente o che devo ancora trovare il coso
per consigli come si dice per per aprire
le già sicuri c'è un altro ascensore si
vabbè
salute e farciti what giocatrice
francesco ciao l'ict ciao craybas bacino
è sempre aliens i sei in tema sanità
dove minchia si è finiti probabilmente
bagnato bene no ok mi potevo arrivare
tomorrownow together futures sci
vabbè so veramente da cani cio storage
che poi non è febbre febbre quella via
di mezzo quelli influenzali o diventò
alien o non lo so ma che ci siamo mai
stati prima pino di ascensori porco
demonio che l'eolico
secondo me queste sono porte chiuse che
se vuoi puoi tornarci per prendere dei
potenziamenti ma non è necessario che tu
lo faccia
grazie francesco chi se ne frega delle
porte di potenziamenti noi siamo forti
così gli starnuti sco addosso c'è
l'influenza e muore perché non hanno gli
anticorpi gli alieni buona guarigione un
bacione pro grazie grazie però che se
sei asia 1997 grazie asia potrei fare lo
youtuber quello che spiega ho sentito
cose brutte
una merda su quattro la torcia ioni
necessario dice no no no no indiscussa
via era vabbè carica stata già scusatemi
non sapevo ci fosse aliena anche in
nepal un'ora che scendo con gli
ascensori queste ovunque o ce n'è più di
uno
ciao denny grazie mille per la nazione
saresti disposto a fare un non posso
dirlo perché femminile con alien certo
subito immediatamente ma proprio mai
solo se è femmina pilsen love favia in
good luck pulita la mia grazie superiori
prossimo super loro il bravo su valori
blues arrivo un nuovo mela favino steve
coleman lo zio però grazie e adesso mi
ricorderò entrato superiori bronze voi
non so se avete mai visto sta roba tipo
una volta ha davanti un altro che
proviamo a che fa bonolis hanno fatto
una domanda su di me ha detto come si
chiamano youtuber italiano con più
iscritti e ce la fa vj wla giovanni è
una di queste domande era superiori pd
sposterà su per loro i bros fossi
chiamato my super loro ingrosso mi sarei
ammazzato comunque spettanti ai bloccato
proprio il portellone
ma ce l'ho né colino batterie per la
torcia urlare mi servivano proprio
tantissimo le batterie per la doccia e
chi lo fa è tutto chiuso
serve la torcia ioni per aprire
qualsiasi cosa qua che che ci devo vacua
la navetta provato lasciato l'anno
niente dottor ma su questa parte
facoltativa scusa che devo farmi
ammazzare sempre da dalle iene per
cortesia nei che stava fa elemosina
fai rocket league per la finisco alien
faccio un po di di rocket magari quindi
no era giusto qua e vada è chiusa la
porta è chiusa a esita che sorry sorry
i'm e scemo all rafa mi giocai brasov e
sarà che non è mai stato così facile
basta superare l'asilo e diventi akerman
grazie lisa 21 37 ricordate non si sa
mai che serve barria port mappa
aggiornata quanta roba sto trovando che
mi chiama io torcia al plasma minchiata
roba la torcia al plasma non di qua è
giusto almeno se lo prenda navetta
allora gli portava altra parte
chiarissimo passava la torcia ioni a ok
liberano chiare non doveva atterrare
l'ho già detto non abbiamo ricevuto il
tuo messaggio
avevamo capito che avresti a posto
identificati identifica il tuo
gioielliere rilassati rifatto ritardo
cosa gli ha detto a riccardo dov'è
finita la sicurezza è qui davanti a te
minchia siamo a posto grande iron man
non lo so è un omaggio portato qui da
marlowe il capitano della necid ora la
nave che ha trovato la scatola nera è un
posto sicuro su questa stazione quelle
creature se ne vanno in giro i simpatici
della sics
i droidi di merda ripreso già stai calmo
però a taylor servono pure il centro
medico ha bloccato non possiamo portarla
lì c'è un unità di supporto vitale al
quartier generale
andiamo allora davvero andiamo insieme
ma non solo io la sala controllo navette
va bene vado vado vado
ne parliamo dopo devo andare devo andare
però il problema a me servirebbe la
torcia con la per aprire la porta perché
come vi ho detto l'altra volta io non ho
i medi keating sto malissimo gioco il
made chi si trova qua non aspettano
quale non questa porta qua ce n'è
un'altra dunque di porta dove si trova
il medico che qua in giro e per aprirla
mi serve la torcia joniche non so quindi
se mi fa del piacere di è un po brutta
st parte della nave sensi corriva nel
regno di qua
vabbè apriamo
gli androidi servono solo a romperti
l'appello so lo so ma io vivo negli
ascensori vivo de io prendo ascensori di
continui il suo gioco com'è possibile
poi tra l'altro stava parlando tra
l'altro ha detto andiamo andiamo al a
prendere questo dobbiamo prendere a ok
da portare di attivare il testimone
andiamo ad attivare sistema di trasporto
e vado solo io
vabbè allora dimmi vai a prendersi mai
ad attivare il sistema non andiamo se
poi faccio solo io le cose che gesù
granata flash
sarebbe utile trovare il coso per i
medici però fa niente via via sistema di
transito della console principale questa
la console
se la schiaccio succede qualcosa
qualcosa mi dice di sì però vabbè dai
proviamo o mi metto a giocare a qualcosa
disabilità di sono figure quindi che
vuoi da me
so che c'è qualcuno qui dentro l'arco
demonio porco ci ho ripensato perché se
faccio casino magari mi ammazza che
faccio lo ammazzo sto qua fermo ma
[ __ ] se ali e mi becca adesso sono
cavoli miei
ciao ecco sapevo lo sapevo io lo sento
sento eppure lo sentono anche vendute
che ragazze in bordello c'è alien per
forza lo sento però non sta arrivando va
bene forse non riesce ad entrare vabbè
non importa torciglioni necessaria e o
il generatore non va cosa devo fare
continua a schiacciare finché non va
cos'è sta roba qua usa la leva c'è una
leva a potevo fare questa cosa fa senza
ammazzarlo ma chi se ne frega
abbiamo i colpi usiamo i no tirarne
un'altra c'è un'altra canzone
chiariamo harry things
obiettivo assistance sì sì ma chi è no
no no veloce dai dai vieni trova ci
torna alla stazione della navetta ma che
ci vuole lo so ripi all ascensore si
ieri vieni vieni qui sì sì mi fa romano
e veloce veloce noi vs guasto che culo e
guasto sequestata l'ascensore porca
vacca schifosa
no dai non ci credo ho trovato cerioni
veloce però che sta arrivando tipo
quanto tempo vi prende una torcia ma in
chi è che emma e nora che aspetta fermi
c'è un problema devo usarla qua per
riattivare tutto devo usarla il problema
è che non posso c'è l'androide o lo
ammazzo devo ammazzare android con
ammazzo android o non mi faccio più
vedere però difficile che che non mi
trovi più ci avesse proprio orbo sì dài
proviamoci
la vacca quanto dura su qua o un'ora e
mezza schifoso l'aido batteria per la
torcia bene ed è un ora per ammazzare
l'androide un ora ci sono fatti imbò di
piombo tonfa elettrico a kreuth ronfa
elettrico dove ho già detto ragazzi il
tonfo elettrico non fa niente banca e
mosche
ma dai bossi si è arrivato un fabre
ammazzandole lo sapevo vabbè dai poi lo
usiamo e gli ho fatto mille in shop sono
soddisfatto mi va bene così la prossima
volta usiamo il tono sori e non
non sapevo fosse il compact necessario o
il volume della voce altissimo senza
seri devo abbassare da temi conferma se
devo abbassare il volume della voce
no
elga pannello enorme a aspettano magari
c'era qualcosa poiché non ho preso tipo
questo non devo alzare con via via le
navette va bene niente entriamo qua
abbassa il volume vi aspettate un attimo
allora tra l'altro ho ridotto a icona
potuto semplicemente cambiare schermo
scusatemi sono pigro ok adesso dovrebbe
essere un po meglio
non l'ho abbassato di tanto ho fatto una
via di mezzo che donna che donna il tipo
non è che dice no no tranquillo
tranquilla e ti aspetti andiamo
va beh ciao max si puoi conoscermi se
fosse una ragazza sarebbe molto più
facile usa leva io non ho capito perché
ci sono le porte chiuse con le leve
perché serve tanto sono passato nato qua
e là votava aspettarmi ma scusami sono
tornato qui subito gli ho detto di
andare figura col demonio
dai dai dai pedalato devo salvare che da
un ora che continua a correre
il bello è che quando metti caso il per
salvare la partita non è che te la salva
subito ti rimane un attimo perché se c'è
qualcuno che ti sta per ammazzare ti
ammazza porco demonio figurazione
arrivan di la cava cà schifosa
devo creare qualcosa e non a volte kalac
che è successo che che è successo mi
hanno sputato addosso v non ho capito
vela sia successo sia perché uno sputo
di vita quindi è successo stiamo
accorciati e non sapevo da che parte
arrivassero capito io devo prendere
quella navetta lì è come la prendo c'è
gente ci vuole
madonna conti sono rega sono tantissimi
perché prova di strati con fleurs
software
il razzo ma non qui idiota figurati se
non lo mettevo nel punto sbagliato il
flirt proprio dove non dovevo mette
volevo lanciarlo io porco schifo è
arrivata la navetta agli enti prego per
una volta che ci devi essere essi c ma
non ci credo l'amaca sono scemi sono
scemi sì mi guarda no
scarica pistola scarica la pistola
lavoro visto che è scemo o per una volta
decidere serali e non c'è vabbè mi
chiara che devo prendere assolutamente
un medico faccio veramente schifo mi
ammazzano subito un colpo grazie
soprattutto super testone che bel nome
catherine deans all'aspettativa
art attivare allora com'è che si lancia
prendi la mira
tieni premuto ernie piazza quindi così
dai veloce navetta schifosa laida
dai dai dai dai dai dai e lancia un
altro bar da lì dobbiamo dividerci
sicuro fa schifo da nessuno nemmeno più
così certo dai party però ok ciao ciao
simpatico
alla fine servivano dice che nel primo
episodio sono stato sei ore a tentare di
distrarli invece alla fine serviva
veramente il razzo dei deficienti
quoziente intellettivo di una scarpa
usata raggiungi samuel taylor agli
ufficiali
ciao francesco grassi della nazione
thinapp rigiocherà così insieme e
guardalinee si gioca il single player
appena facciamo dei giochi in
multiplayer per le live super volentieri
appena produco questa modalità nuova
faccia matteo è una nota riccardo
ciabatte grazie mille prodotti
[Musica]
dopo cioè o qualcuno spiega sta roba che
è successa non mi hanno visto neanche
per sbaglio
tra l'altro difficoltà c'è non è più la
difficoltà easy che avevo messo qualcosa
medikit figura
alla fine scala verde ok siamo al sicuro
ma sono loro i loro piani del cazzo non
hanno funzionato molto stato tu hai
fatto funzionare le navette bel lavoro
seguiremo al sicuro potreste chiudere
chemical co addosso se avete voglia che
bello e mi fate aprire le porte fate
fare qualcosa
beh il dipartimento di qua come stati
già tornerà in forze molto sei riuscito
a far funzionare la navetta prepara la
prossima mossa
senti ho da fare o marlowe in cella il
farabutto gr in possesso della tua
scatola nera in un'orbita di parcheggio
intorno al gigante gassoso quel figlio
di [ __ ] non vuole darci codici di
comando per avvicinarlo magari puoi
provare vado io o il potere della
fagiana che condiziona tutti tranquillo
fra nuovo lusso vedersi qua c'erano cose
da poter sbloccare evidentemente si
guarda che mi cerca mi chiamo riti sono
quella compagnia che brutto che la mamma
mia nella scatola vuota
mia madre era sul nostro amo quando è
sparito 15 anni davvero non abbiamo
trovato già un vocabolario incredibile
soddisfatto la mia cazzo dai successo
devo andarmene da qui
magari fossi a parlarci non polpa vige
nel 2013 a meno male che è partito il
filmato sono continuava a randellare la
porta grazie antonio portata di tasto
faso uncharted il live o a episodi li ho
giocati già tutti e due quindi sola
trama e non posso sono io questo a
comando lui è una back mission cioè la
missione vecchia vabbè avete capito se
io a questo è quello che è successo che
ho capito quando quando hanno sbloccato
quando anno si sblocca non hanno
scoperto ai e quindi sarà un pianeta
che figata
ma ricorda ossa parte quindi dove fece
ali dove l'hanno trovato la prima volta
tutti qui si vede niente figurati segui
segnale va beh
e dice così quindi io non è non porto
uncharted so perché l'ho già fatto e
della stoffa per lo stesso identico
motivo avevo già fatto anche all'inizio
lection però uncharted della sua fase li
ho fatti molto più recentemente da solo
per i cavoli miei ho fatti capito solo
esclusivamente per questo non lo avrei
portato sto veramente morendo
certo che mi chiama meteo più positivo
poteva esserci ma che schifo
la nebbia sullo schifo o
c'è questo è il vostro dovere aliens
seconda malattia
aspettate qui tra un passaggio oltre il
blocco la parola
mi fai da sgabello aiuto a forse vuoi
passare sopra ho visto
ti ami su
a est quebec e bel posto per vivere
piace di sicuro non è firenze questo
posto qua né verona orribile sta roba
qua che è
siete voi che siete andati i mezzi dei
semi mamma mia
sembra milano quando c'è la nebbia forte
sto bene c'è mancato poco
il volo è come lo stesso tragitto da
marte prof
grazie mille per le emozioni che ci fa
provare prego ten di geyser o la nebbia
questa emotivamente fortissimo
un salto di qualità la mia vita
trovato qualcosa io trovo qualcosa ma
che ho trovato niente si sa ancora st
sciacca alien girata allora non sono poi
per trovare alien è stata una io ho la
piazza la carica piazza bomba non me la
ricordo stava comunque di a me l'hanno
trovato suo amico lavoro questa parte
bueno sono quasi saltato in aria ma
chissenefrega
ecco questo ha mai c'è la torcia
incorporata no andiamo io io non vedo
niente non serve a niente la mia dolce
metti un terzo installare visto cagando
sotto vale più o meno c'era adesso non
sta succedendo niente ma occhio
ecco pensa che schifo essere lì avere
tipo il mio stato di salute acqua
attuale aveva con l'influenza pensa che
brutta storia
non vedo un metro fico salentina è
diventato
perché siete qua non potevate andare a
fare la spesa all'esselunga
no qui a caso è quella non è una 500
servirebbe capire in questo me ne deve
fregare ametista nave a fa transizione
la transizione che ci salviamo sopra si
trova la fonte del segnale sì sì sì beh
list i pantaloni comunque sarà molto
cari io vorrei capire un attimo dove
stiamo andando
perché stiamo andando lì perché stiamo
seguendo questo segnale ti stai
avvicinando ad alien beh grazie di
avermelo detto non avevo intuito per
niente diamanti l'anti il dow non sec
non l'ho mai giocato tanto il dow ma non
mi pare che ci sia su pc o sbaglio
quanto lenti per arrivare a eccola la
porta me la fai ti seguo da quando vedi
100.000 salve grazie mille samus entra
nel relitto
potresti togliere che sei veramente
lenta vado avanti grazie gentile faccio
io perché sei veramente una persona
lentissima e fai schifo
così grazie spyker ragazzini le molto
apprezzato dai famila scalea no c'è
un'altra via sorry ti levi tipo ti puoi
togliere tipo i
grazie gentilissimo gentilissima ci
siamo raga esplora il relitto ci siamo
ciao a errori mi saluti tante volte
giochiamo qualche volta allora c'è un
errore grammaticale in questa frase ti
saluto tante volte perché ai problemi di
udito
quindi ti saluta una volta sola ciao eri
e giochiamo qualche volta volentieri
quello appena appena parto che è live
dove posso giocare con voi o merda
questa vista che la predetta anche nel
video originale nella confermate si sta
roba qua tra l'altro infine adesso cosa
dobbiamo trovare quella di vita ora è di
nostra proprietà diritti dire culo il
bomber cosa te ne fai di sta roba qua
non è proprio un cagnolino
e allora prendiamo quello che possiamo
che schifo ma che schifo c'è qualcosa
qua
beh
[Musica]
scopriamo localizza segnale di emergenza
ok mi dici dove è più o meno ma non c'è
proprio la mappa e posso salire la sopra
bravo fa miseri a metalli va messa lì
bravo persone inutili alla vita servono
solo per farmi da sgabello
se io facessi astronauta con uno
sgabello portatile avrei come se fosse
una crew dalla mia parte non di più cioè
non servono a niente
ciao ale la sim milanese
porca vacca disattiva segnale emergenza
va bene
staccati le pile
sai che accarezza disattivato lo so cosa
sia successo molto bene cos'è che
successo cosa ho fatto
argano e un argano cosa fare la grazie
antonio molto gentile dunque niente ci
deve essere nebbia ovunque se non sono
contento
se
questo è successo lì proprio nel momento
in cui ho tolto il segnale cos'è c'è un
treppiede facciamo un video ci mandate
mi guardate mice non so come come salgo
io qua mi arrampico vi ricordo che non
ho le braccia a noi invece ce l'ho che
strano nei giochi non puoi mai
arrampicarti che succedono ma non è
spuntata mette messa poi sta roba che
hai per calarsi giù
l'avevo già trovato io prima questo
complimenti per la scoperta bravo ma ho
già visto prima e che mi fa il 6 alberto
angela che trovai buche sono stato io a
trovarlo il cazzo adattare è opera mia
mamma milano
senza faccia ti voglio bene anche io un
saluto anche a tua mamma ei strong
grazie andrea molto gentile io sto
veramente male
ho preso anche la tachipirina ragazzi
cosa si fa quando si ha la febbre io che
non sono umano non lo so
ecco di sicuro non è un problema suo nel
gioco adesso amico mio che sei lì sotto
mi dici cosa aprendo al posto della
tachipirina per la febbre
poi ho provato a prenderne due dita
torino e 500 non cambia niente se
diventa mille c'è ancora la febbre di
date qualcosa contro la febbre per
cortesia
sacco di uova
ci serve una pentola gigante per farebbe
senti hai una tac i pinoli
adesso ne apre un ace proprio il video
non va bene la cinematica di lui che
apre la l'uovo si apre da solo guarda
dentro sei un chihuahua
se un bulldog sono nessuno di questi due
ma ti salta in faccia la mano di ai 32
neanche 321 provavi a prescindere
benissimo e questo è quello che è
successo quando hanno avuto il primo
contatto con alien perché ali e mi pare
che siano per chi non lo conosce sono
stilisti cosi che sono tipo a forma di
ragno che ti ti ti si attaccano in
faccia e poi ti fanno entrare dentro il
corpo un parassita che poi crescere il
tuo corpo essi e lode quindi tu schiatti
dà vita a questo alien e poi si ingrossa
e diventare fatto una riassunto
scientifico accurato era così io ho
detto una cagata credo altro monito qua
di asti monito ancora devo capire a cosa
servono a parte leggere raccoglie i
lanciafiamme dove come perché quando
aiuto
dov'è dammi qui mio grazie
gentilissimo gli animali hanno paura
dell'uomo
spero sia così
c'è uno trovato del caricatore per il
tonfo
sia lodato gesù cristo e posso provarlo
vi prego vi prego vi prego fate melo
provare vi prego vi prego non trova un
nurofen aspirina dice la mamma grazie
proprio a prendere l'aspirina perché
devo provare lanciafiamme prima cioè la
priorità dove è andato quello di prima
dov'è il tipo dov'è eccolo stai per un
attimo fermo un attimo che vivesse
funziona funziona benissimo ma dove
correvano quelli hanno sbagliato
direzione e da lì quello che stava
andava a fuoco vabbè come ti senti
essere così famoso malato per ai maya
all'aquila un abruzzo certo share grazie
church and co aspetto che devo capire
d'onda boys a un piano per intrappolare
la bestia individuo ok
devo isolare alien minchia che l'idea
che compagni che si sono laureati ad
harvard che ciò è complimenti bravi
ragazzi sono contenti di avere dei
compagni intelligenti come bravi
vediamo proprio in faccia a dalian
bravissimi è così che si giocano si è
detto
[Musica]
samuel 6 dal porto infatti il disastro è
già successo
ora possiamo solo ammazzare il nostro
speriamo anche se dubito ciao francesco
grazie per la senti piace d'occhio
google come manga anime guarda sei
cascato a pennello perché l'ho guardato
ieri sera c'è da voi già visto io ho già
visto che urlo riguardato il riserbo
proprio incredibile già tre anni che non
lo vedevo se non di più
mi chiamo che ieri sera lo guardavo non
ho mai se non ho mai seguito la seconda
serie però vabbè
mi auguro
[Musica]
i gamer prince raggiungi la torre sintex
lorenzo ciao galantuomo ai tanti
svizzera che chiamò i soldi peace
brocchi
ok sono del monopoly vero
grazie io quando leggo chf non capisco
mai che cosa minchia voglia dire però
immagino sia un sacco da quello che è
scritto
porcaccia vacca non conosco la
conversione però che grazie immagino
siano un sacco non dovevi tra l'altro
anche se i ricavi non ce n'è bisogno per
pagare di più per le persone bisognose
pro grazie ai doppi a ogni finale 15 st
troppo mi prendeva lo stesso frazioni la
nota gentile galantuomo
d'altronde lo sei di nome e di fatto
ciao vada grazie mille e io devo capire
un attimo dove stiamo perché mi sta
incamminando ok
e qua forse c'è il medico con qui sono
eccolo eccolo quel figlio di tua madre
con ice l'accesso richiesta come torcia
e cosa so io scusa ma la torcia ioni
nego ioni maledetti serve una torcia al
plasma per quel che so una vita a
trovare quella ioni e non era quella e
la gola al plasma troviamo stato al
plasma dove porco demonio mi sono pagato
in mano è andata così
e successo
individui attiva sistema di spegnimento
incendi ma se ciò lanciafiamme li devo
creare incendi conosci ma io l'ho
accademia nome ne ha parlato gianandrea
se conoscete devo andare ancora di orion
web da quello di orio web spero che già
andranno adesso chiedo perchè gli ho
dato del quello i ragazzi ha riguardato
mal consigliato c'è un androide fuoco e
vabbè deduco che le fiamme non faccio
niente agli android
dovevo e l'ho conosciuto grazie a lui ma
non l'ho ancora visto
non vale niente però devi andargli bene
di essere veloce la domanda è questa se
io ho una vita che fa schifo come la
faccio questa parte visto che mi scende
la vita pian piano non c'è un punto dove
mi si aumenta la vita quando fa il
prossimo evento i primi di ottobre e
riesci ad ottobre dicembre
grazie comunque martina un bacino di
manchin che si è aperta c'è gente
chiuditi c'è anche alien che qua
si va veloci
minchia non sapevo che pensavo di essere
morto sapete tipo quando gli sparo che
non muore invece non è morto c'è nel
senso invece è andato indietro figlio ti
lasci una testata la porta in se ne
frega dato e ci ha ragione si è tornato
alla raccolta più vicino c'è grazie al
freddo grazie sarà
[Musica]
ma dov'era android è sparito l'android
con quella porta di se chiudo vela
androide
ma c'è la tipa
i'm sorry c'era un'altra tipo a questo
successo non attaccare gli erano alleati
scusate io ho fatto fuori gente mi
dispiace non usare troppo carburante no
promesso grazie giulia grazie saraga
simile per la donazione gentilissimi e
devo fare sta parte non devo non puoi
aprirti per favore ma chi se ne frega
del codice di accesso ti prego quello lì
è il caso del meriti draga quel coso lì
e il medic it e il medico
giuro su dio non riesco a prenderlo
perché non la torcia al plasma dello
schifo in terra ma di fare lui sa che
cosa incredibile
franchi svizzeri equivale del tipo neuro
eventi quindi mente un sacco grazie
galantuomo avevo anche le persone
bisognose perfetto già lavorato alla
perfetta grazie mille di avermi spiegato
sarah non lo sapevo
viva la svizzera così per caso
io corro tanto devo far saltare in aria
il coso wiki sei pregato e un casinò sta
parte perché mi scende la vita ce
l'androide
mi serve un [ __ ] medico da una vita
non ce l'ho fatto metà gioco senza
medico ma troviamo st torcia al plasma
schifosa un'esercitazione per prima non
c'era del società che fa come egli è
comodo quindi gira lui veloce veloce
veloce veloce veloce veloce veloce
veloce veloce veloce però c'è
gara
ok ma scusami ma mi prende per il culo
ma mi preme la porta di prima è la volta
di pre cosa l'offerta cosa devo fare qua
devo fare in scusatemi una cosa lo scemo
io ho what the fuck ma non c'era bisogno
di passare a pagare va
e io che ero convinto no non c'è bisogno
di passare qualche tentava di entrare là
dentro non c'era bisogno e non lo so
credo che salta tutto immagino che deve
andargli l'anno no non c'entra niente
cosa mi serviva a far stare
e allora niente equipaggiano la tanto
sociali
anzi se è sparo che così quelli gli
spacca lì però non mi conviene farlo
personali né spacca pure me quindi
facciamo così da marrazzo la mirada
milan 0 0 0 0
poi vedo che finché ce l'ho in mano non
lo vede quando lo lancio lo vede parte
vi ho trovato no forse questi sono
alleati lega
forse questi nomi cagano
ai ragazzi non mi cagano scusatemi sono
scemo celata revolver
scusate pensavo fossero nemici aveva
meglio così
aspetto che ci accompagnino che non
corriamo perché c'è alien però andiamo
di su bella fa vi saluto dell'arezzo
ciao matteo un bacio anche ad arezzo e
raggiunge i server centrale serve
centrale mi sa che crei credo sia pa
sopra a sinistra giusto dove l'avevo
beccato per la prima volta puoi anche un
gelato si sa mai che te lo chiedo perché
devo leggere un messaggio che ha
lanciato giuliano anche il mio fratello
giocare le isole shaun asif ali e lui mi
sono perso quello che mi ha detto mi
serviva leggere porco demonio devo
aprire la porta devo trovare a corrente
va bene io sono stata preoccupata per
quello che sta succedendo a youtube
perché senza esse non posso vedere in
più il mio grande idolo to idolo to the
più grande idolo tu grazie per quello
che fa grazie a tecniche per la
donazione per questa frase bellissima e
simpatica e
vedremo
la cosa che mi aspetta la cosa che mi fa
un comando fratello roberto
bravo riccardo si può passare una
domanda importantissima
viva gli alieni alessandro orco demonio
una domanda molto importante la torcia
al plasma visto che è di vitale
importanza che io la trovi voices che
voi sappiate e questo non mi ha visto
come voi sappiate sd standard la si
trova nel gioco o poi anche non trovarla
e tra devi andare a cercare perché se si
trova a porco demoni una visto se si
trova dice la chitarra simpatico se si
trova di standard bene se non si trova
in standard me la devo andare a cercare
me lo dovete dire perché devo trovarla
per forza
quindi se la troviamo standard standard
mentre vado avanti nella trama ok se non
nome lado andare a cercare quindi di te
ma vi prego
come faccio una ricerca mariga
forse faccio in tempo a cominciare su
lanciafiamme
schifoso come sono vivo come come faccio
a essere vivo impossibile
che fa ma come gli ha sparato addosso
come nadai gli ho sparato mentre
iniziata la douce avevo fatto una
provata avevo fatto una provata rovinata
cui sia ho fatto una roba incredibile
cavolo che babbo cache rosi che orribile
abbiamo fatto una cosa incredibile ma
rovinata porco demonio ti voglio bene
farvi anche io giovanni grazie ti voglio
tanto bene voglio veramente esagerata
che ci voglio un bene che proprio tu non
un bene che io non ti so descrivere
giovanni giovanni proprio un bene
dell'anima giovanni così ha preso porto
potresti farti ore sul potresti farmi un
riassunto dell'ultima live sono morto
tante volte fine scale ciao favicon le
due anime preferito guarisci presto un
bacino
ciao gaia un bacino per giugno anni ma è
preferito ed è noto il secondo preferito
è suo
se guardate online
un bacino a te
guarisci presto speriamo grazie chris
tara andrea dobbiamo capire come stare
fermi ma allo stesso tempo c'è come
stare in silenzio nello stesso tempo
muoviamo il culo perché dobbiamo
assolutamente raggiungere il punto e ne
avete risposto per la torcia ioni per la
torcia al plasma che quella cosa che mi
interessa
c'è qualcosa quale serve a qualcosa sta
stanza ma siedo fuoco ai consigli
android va bene ce li faccio fuori no
cole tom fa gonfiamo li facciamo modo
per sbucciare le armi in fretta a si
posso fare con la rotella del mouse non
lo sapevo minchia a dirlo prima bismil
risparmiato tanto di quel tempo sarei
risparmiato i verbi i verbi
da noi previsto e marmo guardano e cieco
non vede e stato bellissimo se ne va ed
è ostile perché ha gli occhi rossi non è
mica mica sono scemo e vai nei palazzi
che figata
la torcia default che innovare grazie è
stato stupendo aveva cominciato perché
mica vado
no craxi c'e alien per forza ho sentito
il condotto chuyen no dovevo andare di
qua mai
ora co schifo di grosso su cosa a questa
è la porta del centro che prefetto mi
sono ri connesso al al punto di prima
perfetto molto bene sintonizzatore
accesso ragazzo veramente cosa ho preso
non ho visto sto di uno schifo
possono scemo io lo sento pratico non si
paga lo stesso rumore poterlo blocco ha
sentito il rumore orribile va bene
scusami usato rifare acqua era cosa che
pirla e non l'avevo visto isole sto
jesus ti ringrazio
niente niente mi caga colon detto non mi
sta cagando sta programmando scemo isole
si nel sito di su continua a guardare
quello che vuole ma questo ma scusami e
io pensavo fossi uno stile
ecco perché non mai pagato prima avella
vede io allora ragazzi sono orbo io ma
mi sembra che ci abbia gli occhi rossi
ditemi voi se non sembrano rossi da
lontano sembrava fosse cattivo
allora c'era modica no perchè se no era
cieco non aveva visto e con alien vi
ricordate se posso camminare anche in
piedi o devo stato fatto eco marciato
bello sto tizio sembra bella mattina per
la torcia al plasma di proseguire nella
storia grazie mille a posto allora a
posto
sei un mito nonostante la febbre stai
facendo da lei per farci compagnia ma
anche voi mi fate compagnia compagnia
vicenda nelle live non è un favore che
io faccia voi solo anche un favore che
voi fate a mano ha comunque ali e non
può passare anche nei condotti si ve lo
dico io non ricordo bene
sì però se i solo tutto ci sono dentro
anch'io è un problema se si è chiara
questa faccenda accovacciato è meglio
accovacciato le stessero l'accesso
richiesta di morta acide tuma però non è
che così fai più casino scusami problema
tanto qua non equa adesso se muoio mi
incazzo isola il corridoio reception del
se come ci arrivo di qua no perché
isolato e adesso vediamo
no
è vero che sembravano rossi gli occhi
dell'android uguali cioè non sa di qua
scusatemi non ho visto io non ho visto
né io non vedo le qui io sono più cieco
degli androidi se come questo quadro si
incazza lo sto presentimento strano
android e di qua
ecco ci sono già ma dai
devo attivare il comando e che ne so
sparato un numero randomico niente
troviamo stop a me lo dai economy dal
codice something codici magi non ce
l'abbia lui cioè cosa dice no serve
codice sun casino io lo trovo il codice
ma tra l'altro ci ho pensato adesso mi
aiuti mente solo adesso ma il botto
nella chat che 21 37 grazie ragazzi
perché non ho idea di come trovarlo
grazie ragazzi veramente non sapevo non
ho idea di dove si trovi quindi lo
scrivo mi fido 21 37 erano giusto
17 02 sempre questo è e 21 37 non va non
va mi sa che lo devo giustamente trovare
devo andare a trovarla a 77 89 77 89
c'era il codice era dentro come se io
metto lo ammetto la password del
computer e mette un blocco note sul
monitor e scrivo la password del
computer questa che cazzola menti a fare
non ho capito
sandra c'è un pacchetto di trasmissione
di routine che la compagnia ha inviato
da un pacchetto sì sì bravo a mandare
vocali
ok salva comunque non serviva a ti
raccomando vi è attivato o no non era
quello a non quella era l'audio solo
signori devo capire come si faccia cosa
che non ho capito devo essere in diretta
ogni domenica devo cambiare il volte il
botto e continua a dire che sono in live
e ogni domenica dalle 14 30 alle 19 30
ma non è vero
non credete al booth mente
ecco da quello che stavo dicendo prima a
via all'isolamento e non trovavo la
funzionaria l'isolamento pensavo fosse
quella no
il bot in chat dice cazzate non
credetegli ilary ci sono a domenica
esatto non è vero avevi sono ventilate
modifica del boca adesso mi è venuto in
mente
secondo me per l'affare fa una brutta
fine tra dieci secondi quindi questi gli
occhi come scegli tu sei a posto
l'hockey bianchi mi chiamava capirlo
prima ormai cassa acustica v2 male
medikit no
i touch del bot
isa cioè il bo non credete ai bot
neanche agli androidi sono degli stronzi
tutti quanti comunque io a me conviene
fare questa cosa qua razzo li puoi
fabbricare no cosa che puoi fabbricare
la cassa acustica la bomba fumogena la
molotov la tubo bomba io devo fabbricare
le cose perché se non fabbrico le cose
poi mi trovo con pieno zeppo di cose e
non posso prendere altri o altri oggetti
quindi conviene fabbricarla roba appena
cielo ecco parte di fabbricare un attimo
2 robe che mi manca addirittura un pezzo
che sono continua a trovare oggetti non
me li fa mai prendere giusto e monoposto
bianca c'è un miliardo di componenti b1
fa avrei dovuto farlo dall'inizio era la
prova be chissenefrega interessare il
medico per il resto melacca vicchio
marco demonio
e vabbè io sto pian piano che lo risolo
lo vedremo sempre di più perché
ovviamente si restringe il che ha
parlato
l'androide immagino sono gli sarebbe
saltato già in bocca man mano che i
destri e che le stringo l'area lo
vedremo sempre di più
parlo di alien cosa hai ammazzato giusta
persona sia d'aiuto bene continua ad
ammazzare gente in compagnia
ma la giornata letto e dicevo ho perso
il filo porco demonio mi dicono lo stavo
dicendo sono andato bene ho perso il
figlio mi ricordo che sto dicendo beh
ministro mi sono distratto e si sa
minchia chissà dove vanno a finire
sempre cosi la serie tv preferita l'oro
è comunque ragazzi fatemeh nelle domande
in live ancora anche per questo dovete
fare domande rispondo che se l'è
preferita e prison prison break e poi
lost ti piaceva un punch pennello visto
non mi fa impazzire il genere per quanto
sia un geniale vantaggio ma
semplicemente io che non al prezzo non
che non mi piace è che non pace non
c'era un tipo prima semplicemente io
sono a meno a me piace più ostile verso
there not capito non che sia brutta anzi
fantastico
solo che sono gli horrors trans it
germano è
è capire cosa per isolare la stanza
mondo sta sapete voi ma corrono non
corro scherzo ma non è dove isolare la
stanza di serve 23 un coso per isolare
la stanza ma non so dove sia
immagino sia qua dietro all'oro bailo
passato minchia
ci sono pagati in mano e non mi sia
accorto che ci sono meno male a posto a
posto non se n'è accorto e scemo meno
male serie j
sa che cosa ho fatto ma guai per
sigillare sigillo l'aqua si girò minchia
come francis pensi che finirà questa
faccenda di youtube ma penso io sono un
positivo perché son vivo ma è io sono
molto positivo nelle cose purtroppo il
piacere quindi è questo a minami ricerca
o cosa
raga ce l'abbiamo nega pranzi mi sono
chiuso da solo devo attendere i rinforzi
ottimo specie non identificate sua linea
detto bene ragazzi è chiuso devo
resistere
ottimo
non ne ho proprio di tempo devi andare
anche velocemente via
tra l'altro io se passo qua sotto mi mi
ammazzo lo so
corri dai dai dai dai dai dai
meno male e mo e ma la domanda è una
come risolo la zona sky devo scappare
basta scappiamo carico abitante mila
fratello capire allora tutti in fondo in
fondo in fondo in fondo in fondo poi a
destra ok
minchia che brutta storia in quale
personaggio qui trovi incluso un drag
dinamico
ma come gli ho dato fuoco
sono ancora vivo sono ancora vivo no non
è vero pensavo bellissimo ha detto dove
vado è poi morta
no che peccato i personaggi si rivede in
prison break e banalmente michael
banalmente simo però è vero perché
ragiona molto sulle cose e sempre zitto
sono io sì però gli oggetti fattagli
dalla fisica vi prego iddio gesù paglia
la fisica soggetti qua
cosa pensi dei commenti non ho fatto in
tempo a leggere
scusatemi laga è difficile che ringrazia
salvatore torenco non salvatore ho
sbagliato a leggere scusami ringrazia
capire grazie nicolò per sempre anno
avevo visto le ultime donazioni
scusatemi
pardon top 6 no grazie
che personaggio e lo so avevano chiuso
dentro ragazzi e se ti pare che abbiamo
fatto tutto sto casino e poi non siamo
riusciti
che palle io mi sarei dovuto sacrificare
per tutti quanti a morire insieme ad
alien isolato alieni selection
ecco perché si chiama gli in isole shaun
perché stiamo cercando di isolarlo ma
che è bello due volte ho dovuto giocarlo
per capirlo due volte nice
minchia ma se non avevo mai capito giuro
giuro scende il cancro piscio di mi devo
sono uscito l'ascensore lo via dove
l'ascensore l'ascensore è per l'ance
mini ok corni cor core e qua no ma mi fa
andare nel condotto
prendi l'ascensore per la jamie e nel
condotto la scienza
sai che hai un attimo non capito bene ha
forse al piano di sopra può essere segna
la scienza acqua
porterei the grudge il live del gregge e
molto devi tagliare tanto degrado perché
è bello ma devi tagliare tante parti
morte quindi praga dove min chiesto
ascensore che non ha sbagliato a
segnarlo non è lì è lassù non lo so
governo francesco che ne pensi di
carichi come persone dell'anime sei un
grande
[Musica]
ahia
si vabbè minchia la gesù pure e ali
necessari paghe cesta il tipo che one
direction cos'è un concerto un evento e
di m
minchia buono nel mio no 26
che palle vabbè cosa ne pensi di cannes
e chi con personaggi e la situazione che
fa grazie francesco non c'era bisogno
tranne chi è molto molto dall'inizio
infanti cioè nel senso è molto infantile
ci sta quindi non mi faceva impazzire
particolarmente poi col tempo matura e
diventa cazzuto quindi mi piace di più
così incazzato perché mi ha fatto uscire
la liberazione
la domanda è una dove minchia stasta
ascensore ragazze lo sapete me lo dite
perchè sapete che non ho idea di dove
meno che sia stata ce n'è uno a destra
la licenza l'ascensore per la gente
sprone solutions
immagino sia passato dove si sa c'è
quella gente perché sennò non ha senso
razzo state lì si è lanciato in faccia
proprio questi si vedono arrivare un
cose in faccia chi lo ha lanciato e
stanno lì due ore dei geni per parlo
poco che tanto che la schietta pure da
questi però parte c'è la porta qui che
scemo
a posto e la scienza
[Musica]
non è qua che palle devo andare
esattamente dove sono questi il problema
è che c'è gente che palle o non c'è un
modo per farli fuori tipo call tonfa
elettrico non c'è modo per distrarli che
stavano battezzato le chiappe rega
c'è un fucile a pompa dai prendilo
cartucce per fucile ma manca ma anche al
fucile prendi fucile cioè fucile fucile
a pompa cartucce per fucile ma se non ho
il fucile
prendilo credo che sia lì l'ascensore
qui sopra ma eccolo lì lo vedo
ma porco demonio porco demonio porco
demonio porco che palle minchia o giuro
mamma mia di stermino studi mi avete
pagato un cazzo lo corri sotto il nome è
facilissima st parte c'è chi giura è una
cagata incredibile come facciano
riuscirci ma rivali e lì mi spiazza il
lanciafiamme in bocca mi corre in faccia
c'è dai cristo
eli
sì lo vedo
mi piace quando ci sta effetto sonoro
bellissimo vuol dire che si stanno
facendo conoscenza lasciamo che facciamo
una scienza ciao alex grazie della
nazione
le live ad un massimo di oro possono
durare all'infinito e no possono durare
all'infinito in realtà dipende quanto
reddito come essere umano non ho possono
andare avanti per anni
a meno che youtube non ti butti giù
porca [ __ ] si chiama visto
io sento gente che urla non la sento io
non la sente lui no no dai
doveva scemo bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
bye sono inciampata no no no fermi cosa
mi che è successo dai cos'è successo
ma è male a mio papà [ __ ] no dai
ragazzi seriamente ma non erano morti
quelli chi mi ha colpito ma cribbio
c'è sabato non l'ho capita di giuro su
dio non lo capirà
era l'unico modo per far uscire di me
e ancora mi ha capito dove vado ma il
lavoratore generale con l'ascensore
scappare cammina
di un gene e roma
come facesse ancora vivo
dai dai ma porco demonio porco ma chi è
che mi spara
chi è che mi spara fa al porto demoni
morti tutti sono morti tutti chi è che
mi stava sparando raga impossibile st
parte vi giuro possono mongoloide ma chi
mi spara chiederti a chi giura non lo
sto capendo cosa ci sarà nelle live dopo
ai e non me lo spoiler
io lo so già il coté la colazione domani
grazie al gentilissimo io vi giuro non
sto capendo chi mi spara
non lo stop è sei volte che muoio dalla
stessa persona che non vedo tra l'altro
c'è anche alien nella stanza quindi la
gente si spaventa e continua a morire da
qualcuno che mi spara e non capisco chi
sia non capisco chi è stavolta mi chiavi
giuro non tocco niente ma vi giuro non
sto capendo c'è proprio una cosa
difficilissima parte che dice un tizio e
vabbè ma vengo di quando facciamo così
da qua
vedo se riesco a risbucare di là da qua
in fondo vado tutto a destra in fondo
sbocco dall'altra parte non sono quella
d'altra parte perché chiuso aspetta
aspetta che no niente questa ma solo
giro facebook dall'altra parte cha du ri
non posso solo che l'altra cuore va
niente scherzavo cassa acustica bravo
questo è un ottimo consiglio cassa
acustica ma magari non adesso però la
cassa acustica prossimo consiglio
grazie perché questa viene dove ci sono
io e non dove c'è la gente
inizia rischiato grossissimo regali
scusami con fuoco non te lo prendi solo
prende solo l'altra politiche con i
video migliori sempre ma da quando ti
prende a schiaffi marco è tutta un'altra
cosa grazie marghe lo so anch'io è
quello il fatto con il problema nora
gasta parte vi giuro su dio è
difficilissimo di sicuro non aiuta il
fatto che non hai mesi però nicchia
orribile carlo no questo no aspetta
aspetta non è che posso passare anche
milano non è giusto giusto ho fatto un
giro stranissimo
se quello non si gira ce la fa ce l'ho
fatta lega
mi chiamo aveva visto che culo o sull
good sei ore per falsa parte molto bene
sono sempre più fiero di me stesso
porca vacca 6 anni
minchia di salvare con quel tonfa rompe
i culi sul serio rega è fortissimo dopo
difficile prendere gli amici ciao
tu sei tranquillo è però passati quasi
sicuri ma ti prego fai piano lo dico io
sono io che schiatto lega udc su hicks
simpatica miglia naruto già tre quarti
di bamba frate mi aprì per favore ci
avrei bisogno ripristino dell'accesso
all'area di aprire stila portano torcia
al plasma china traccia plasma da
prestarmi a c'è il dio è buono l'ho
trovata dorato questo schifo lì
io non ho io vi giuro su dio che le
parole non esistono
per questo gioco le parole non esistono
non esistono quello sta ancora al
computer mi che ho trovata la torcia un
attimo
trovo la torcia mi salta in bocca le
amiche hanno un secondo o comunque sta
andando meglio strike di quella
precedente a livello di come sto
resistendo così ancora lo meno preso
quello che a 1.089 19 certo come non mai
sostituito non c'è una bomba e vabbè
levo gli sciali anche dove vai
chiedo un caffè è sfiga è uscito proprio
mentre stavo pia la torcia al plasma al
plasmon ti piace salmo certo voglia
mauri number one
l'avevo già detto prendi sta cosa veloce
switch sulla luce fiamme perché ti giuro
su dio da tir in testa sta dolci al
padre
[Musica]
ma che cosa cambia dall'altra scusami è
uguale
vai
ok ragazzi dunque se torno alle navette
posso finalmente prendere il medic it
dopo quanto finirai ali e non
sicuramente stasera non è possibile cioè
sicuramente dura ancora una live forse
ancora di più non lo so questo qua è
nemico amico e amico
io ragazzi vi giuro che non capisco mi
chiama neanche il tempo di girarsi e
spararli o madonna o c'è veramente giuro
non la sto capendo sta roba
ma manco il tempo di girarsi incredibile
non mi sono perso pure la minchia so a
ok ti giuro non riesco a girarmi non so
che dire fai parte di queste sono tutte
porte che si aprono
vai vai vai
[Musica]
veloce veloce che questo qua mi che
scende muori immediatamente muoio
incredibile veloce veloce dai veloce
maglia il mancio sull'hotel altro tipo
non hanno toccato no è quello android e
valiani mangia solo forme di vita
android e android è un androide quindi
non è una forma di vita e non solo
mangia per quei motori gli altri invece
se li mangia io vi giuro non ho capito
cosa sia successo abbiamo sto fermo
aspetto che esca porca di una punta ma
sto gioco era così difficile ma io vi
giuro che non me lo ricordavo così
difficile c'è più credibile molto più
difficili di quanto pensassi di quanto
mi ricordassi di caldo mi chiamate marca
vacca veramente un casino fi piano 6 ora
che ti faccia
è schiatta viscido
se stai andando no
ecco perché prima mi ha sentito
share
[Musica]
chiara saliva nella tubatura lo so e non
l'ho vista grazie emiliani quindi sale
occhio alla tubatura subito mi chiamano
eccolo
vedo
se sparo nella tubatura
no non ci conosciamo piacere non è il
momento però di fare le conoscenze
adesso
scusi non volevo attaccarti lo voleva
attaccarti c'era lui di mezzo non voleva
perché rete vuole attaccare lui eh vabbè
ormai gli ho dato fuoco uccidiamolo dai
dai dai
come sa dire qui sopra che questo che
c'è un cross a minchia portello bloccato
e fatto salire un punto che non serve a
niente ottimo so nice
almeno qua e non mi prende sicuro
cav h
cazzo e scarico stato e scarico e carico
e scarico
che palle
mamma mia
c'era che non me n'ero accorto che era
scarico ve lo giuro
ma porca di una pasqua poi sei ore ci
mette attorno agli voleva fare il coso
schivare alien miche 1 ora per fast a
parte un macello
lei esce ciò che vuoi arrivare
immediatamente
tra i giuro non so che di un'ora
stai veloce veloce
minchia figura
ma dai noi abbiamo dato qualche minuto
vai vai
c'è qualche secondo
ok mo torna indietro proprio tutto
cioè voglio salvare la partita sono
minchia no occhio alle foto in alto
salva solo la partita
dov'è cosa dov'era la stai qua mi guardò
dovuto risolvere la partita perché mica
ci ho messo sei ore per far star ora sì
sì sì ma è beccato bravo bravo bravo
complimenti
tanto ci sei tu che schiaccia allora qua
io apro perché sicuramente c'è qualcosa
di interessante sicuro porterei mai di
league of legends ameri
non penso ci giocavo tipo
ma dov'è sentito ma non si è visto
figurati dove doveva andare dove sta
andando io col demonio questo termine
già fatto stesso casinò per sottolineare
qualche cosa c'è niente sto casino per
niente meno male che non me ne vado in
giro per la nave perché non c'è nulla
tranne i medici
no perché giocavo league of legends tipo
tanto chi se ne frega non c'era niente
sei anni fa ci giocavo quindi è passato
un sacco di tempo un veicolo ma come si
gioca e non nel mio proprio non è un
canale la league of legends quel
l'esatto opposto
sui contenuti che sono l'opposto di
problemino tra gli interruttori della
struttura che occorrono la lascio
catanzano a meno che non sia qui si era
qua
madonna potevo non correre perché era
vicino e penso fosse lontano quindi
poteva non col la tipa quale avete voi
ecco infatti scappata c'è la tipa dietro
la tipa dietro niente proprio l'anti
pari ad un saga gara di striscia vabbè
theatre tira dunque lanciafiamme
l'invenzione del 7 sì sì vado
questo è laboratorio no a 0
dai facciamo la tranquilli tranquilli
nella sede a serie sino adesso non sto
correndo la faccio tranquilla proprio
non ho mai tranquillo con comodo
vabbè però miglia si sta roba qua sta
ferma ok
e a te ma questo è un portello ci posso
passare attraverso asi che figata
poco arrivare all in
immagino di sì
cap minchia mi sono salvato per un
millesimo di secondo
mi sono salvato per niente presente c'è
un prima parte secondo mandato
fin quando l'avevo visto lurido schifoso
raga devo stare attento dove devo come
si dice devo stare veramente attenti
perché ho quasi finiti colpite
lanciafiamme vincerò mai stato qua
interruttore la qual cosa per salvare
cammina dai mi fido mi fido mi fido in
filosofia e li yes
minchia
sono andata veramente bene
è andata veramente benissimo che culo
interruttore non posso ricaricare il
nono colpi
eccolo il problema capito
ma c'è un codice d'accesso che non so
starà lì cosa che c'è qua dentro
che sfiga allam ha visto forse
no sì invece sì ma visto proprio va buo
buo gioco è veramente strano a volte
regala lo dico solo perché ho salvato se
non avessi salvato mi sarei incazzato
alquanto ma ho salvato quindi va bene
basta
bene
no non devo farmi beccare a qualcosa lì
che fa casino
il suo terminale mi sa che mi serve sai
sono geni
27 43 27 43 il codice ok per aprire la
cosa lì di fianco si sa mai decidere
dove 74 74 da 27 43
potenzia torcia io devo pure potenzia
pure minchia figurati
ci mancava con la potente il
potenziamento della torcia minchia sta
deve diventare un pokémon ragazzo fine
di colpire non ci abbia me possono
respingerlo ancora una volta o due forze
ecco vai a gesù beh è fatto cosa che c'è
qua non è che centro volentieri e c'è
del sangue però va bene salve preso il
badge image a cosa servono ancora non ho
capito per aprire le stesse per aprire i
posti vicini vero
non mi puoi cercare un condotto di
grosso
c'è un più piccolo io inizializza quindi
devo andare in laboratorio che dai sì
che si può usare il motore i movimenti
semplicemente non vedono non ne ho il
bisogno perché so esattamente dov'è
stai andando
e andato
ok
poi io non devo far casino non devo
camminare
però posso tranquillamente spaccare una
leva e rompere un lucchetto come se
niente fosse
per questo non fa casino no fa casino il
camminare
vabbè parte di questa qua e mi porta
solo semplicemente più vicino alla scala
non importa chi sa dove lo scendere
sai che non sto capendo dove devo andare
grazie mille federica 3 jos e farne tix
farneti
a il lanciafiamme in mano che fàcasino a
si sa e allora si spiegano tantissime
cose e il lanciafiamme che ho in mano
che fa ecco perché mi chiami spuntava da
un momento all'altro in tre secondi
perché lanciafiamme fa casino e mi
chiamo me lo spiega nessuno che ne
sapevo io di te lo prima porco demonio
lo sapevo giuro eccolo ho fatto è teoria
la brava cercato figurati sesto pezzente
non dai e la manata daje daje la manata
dagliela taglierà taglierà mi chiamo lo
ammazzo te lo giudico una scarica mentre
per terra
anzi non gliela do solo perché spreco
colpi comunque non sapevo che tenere
lanciafiamme fuori facesse casinò bello
show lancia vian
non ho ben capito cosa ha fatto sta cosa
però va liberato un android ci ha fatto
quello che non dovevo fare
aspettiamo
e gesù io non li posso toccarti così
sono troppo roventi fai tu ti tocco io
perdo un sacco di vita
come dire a freddo di dover raffreddare
ci devo soffiare sopra
come vede col lanciafiamme di tiscali
limbo stai facendo questo evitando con
la morte mi dai una mano come si
raffreddano sti cosi sono nomi parte il
coso come si raffreddano regala a sori
avvio della corrente necessaria che ho
capito scusa
posso respingerlo solo una volta forse
sottolineo forse perché ho veramente
pochi proiettili proietti carica di
lanciafiamme
ok
lì sopra lì sotto 18 la madonna
che brutto che sei vabbè
è che casino che il lavoro brutto quello
di stato sta nave musicato fa attiva il
carrello attiva attiva
mi sa che ho sbagliato ma non posso
passare di qua molto meglio
a
maledetto fumo non perdere vita che nei
pochi
bassi figurati a sta facendo casino con
lanciafiamme giusto devo ricordarmi che
lanciate a me non lo devo tenere fuori
perché se lo tengo fuori si sente tragga
scusatemi non mi ricordo mai
vabbè dai
è servito
non è servito con fase è una stoccata
wow si è cagato sotto ho visto la paura
nei suoi occhi che non aveva neanche una
paura luglio si è cagato addosso
cagasotto mamma mia
meno male almeno recuperato un po di
corpi perché veramente non avevo più
comunque non ho capito ora perché alien
era molto più difficile ultimamente non
capivo perché io avevo lanciafiamme di
fuori continuamente col lanciafiamme di
fori schiatti e non sapevo
vorrei avviata pirla ma dove avviare
anche cosa aspetta
ma scusami ok ho capito
devo tirare fuori il coso il tipo che fa
fuori che fa lo fa lui suo lavoro per me
perché se lo faccio io poi non riscatto
affari così intendo chiaro giusto wifi
però veloce quanto tempo sto servizio mi
sta lentamente uccidendo l'influenza è
una bella lei nonostante in influenza
vero strano l'influenza mi debilita in
una maniera che voi non potete
immaginare
vai vai così tanto
c'è un composto chiamato capaci
fammi sapere quello sai
che io cammino così raga perché se un
cammino così muoio quindi scusatemi se
mi accovaccia di continuo ma se ne un
casino quando li fai finale gli elfi
screens and very soon questa rai una
figata grazie giovanni anche se sto
morendo dentro inside nel senso che è
proprio ciò l'influenza che incombe
ok non è che devo prendere questa
nicchia pensa che sfiga io il primo è
andato più avanti di quanto dovessi
andare che pirla che potevo farcela
molto prima
oggi minchia che attacco l'influenza
brutta sto andando sta andando in da un
pazzesco ragazza mezz'ora vado a dormire
carlo allorio cede laboratorio di ok
very soon is the new mai hai ragione
anche terna ci hai ragione pure idee i
finali le forest e c'è la prossima
settimana in teoria ragazzi come video
normale non come video live
proposta una parte opposta fondo chi se
ne frega
salve poi andiamo una bella giornata è
tesserato accesso a c'è gente che io vi
lascio qualche non so se siete amici
nemici ospedale vediamolo amici o nemici
amici
ciao si è carina tipo milano po più
scura però posso fare una cosa [ __ ] vi
prego
io merito l'inferno sono una persona
orribile orribile me lo merito
ma ne è valsa la pena tantissimo
continuiamo
[Musica]
scusami ha viste le batterie non me ne
davi per lotti sai che c'è qua
ma visto te ne vai però ti ho chiamato
un attimo poi tornare a casa
[Musica]
questa roba lo ha fatto chi se ne frega
tanto non c'è niente da dentro via dire
ci sono pagate ricaricabili tono c'è un
corso per la ricarica di lanciafiamme
con la mi servirebbe tantissimo questo
avete niente sono solo lì per ammazzare
la gente
via
13 come se come non avere niente devo
arrivare in fondo al corridoio veloce
devo usare anche un coso per aprire la
porta veloce veloce veloce veloce veloce
veloce veloce non ce la farò mai
mourinho tantissimo grazie ci provo lo
stesso
dai
preferiresti grazie aldo però donazione
preferiresti essere un universo di
alieno di auto di alien perché outlast e
proprio bruttissimo a livello psico lama
alien alien tutta la vita oddio in auto
credo di poter credo che riuscirei a
scappare più easy perché alien dove vai
se in un'astronave quindi fuori prima o
poi quindi al livello di location forse
però aliena livello di cattivi dove
siamo
sì però devi andare fuori dalle palle
non può star lì e vivere lì
si è fatto niente asi si è fatto vai vai
stato a fare qua ripristina corrente mi
sa che ci siamo arrivati
c'è lui riusciti a fare questo pezzo
dai da ripristinati chi sia ripristinata
portico schifoso demonio per un niente
non ce l'ho fatta raga quella e quelle
computer li ci arriverò mai
come ci entrò lì a fare tutto il giro ma
siamo sicuri e mi sa di sì devo fare
tutto il giro pensa che sfiga
incredibile non posso ricaricare
lanciafiamme tipo con gli estintori
faccio il contrario ripristino della
cornea
dai dai che cosa pensava ci fosse
lasciarla salva prima salva saltati
prego stato veloce veloce veloce veloce
perfetto sono contento ok
e ho capito quello che mi hai detto lo
faccio subito cosa che mi ha detto dei
prezzi è stato qua dentro
ma quella dove sono arrivato scusami
scemo
dove sta roba che devo eccolo che pirla
nuovo visto
non importa ho capito dove devo andare
l'importante quello scusate sono ho
capito in ritardo cosa devo fare
e peccato si sia come passione perché
non sono abbastanza l'ultimo dove la
stanza di prima
dov'era il computer confina usato
ah ok ci sono due stanze quindi ok
niente non ho capito
laboratorio ok c'è questa stanza non è
segnata dalla small marmo e quando entrò
mela sblocca e assegnato proprio scemo
dai dai
ciao mister robot
attirata quale eccesso scappa dal
laboratorio per un dopato a va bene
quello di poterlo fare carica
quanto tempo mi chiama tesi da erika
rifare una luna una rotella c'è una
rotella usala la rotella usa la rotella
minchia un'ora per tirar fuori
lanciafiamme un'ora cristo dai minchia
sei uno scherzo di un essere umano ma
porco demonio neanche mia nonna ci mette
un'ora e mezza per ricarica dai fai
serio cristman dai veloce veloce veloce
cristo veloce veloce
quello che devo andare cesco subito
proprio sito attivato il cazzo sedi
anche doveva devo scappare dai veramente
no no no no no no no
non ci credo mi hanno fatto saltare
insieme a tali annuncio parole non ci
credo avevano fatto saltare insieme a
tali sono isolati insieme ad alien bene
[Musica]
su morto che non mi ricordo come va a
finire
mi hanno isolato insieme ad alien raga
aggiungi la chiusa da aria esclusa tanto
mi stava seguendo era dietro di me l'ho
perso ha chiuso a daria sta qua
i toni
[Musica]
presso riza minchia sono morto
pressurizzate
[Musica]
no ma seriamente niente ma da qua un
corpo demonio
poi quanti esce per forza secondo me
allora devo fare se i giri con questa
parte orrifica
ora perché aspettare un secondo infiniti
ma un secondo bastava più
bastava proprio un secondo in più e
uscivo si posso usare i condotti sotto
terra in realtà
prima
se le botole per terra
no io corro quando anche andando piano
non riesco a farle robe che va beh non
corriamo che vedevo di un goriano
amica ma è tutto collegato al suo posto
che figo mi posso passare proprio in
mezzo giusto so good
[Musica]
ma non è tutto collegato tutto sembrava
strano arriva vero arrivato dovevo
arrivare subito bene non corrono un coro
ton qui non corro non corro tanto muoio
uguale per assicuro chiama sono entrato
nelle botte che non esca uscire né
scendere e salire di mango
ora
[Musica]
poi tutto se con tutto sto bordello che
c'è per la metà dei sentieri
[Musica]
luca porca vacca po schifo l'avevo detto
che moriva anche se stavo accovacciato
avevo detto io correrò saccoccia non
cambia in gaza che palle d'acqua ogni
volta che palle
ci credo
arrivammo tranquilli accovacciati e
morirò uguale però ci riproviamo questa
parte porca vacca che casino da voglio
farla prima di finirla live maledizione
tanto anche un 14 minuti 13 anzi ce la
farò ce la faccio promesso
[Musica]
grazie grey fox direttamente la metal
gear grazie al freddo grazie al libro
rocket league da una 10 quanto ti piace
fa vi e viii
se dovessi dargli un voto sarebbe 8
rocket league è un gioco della madonna
solo che sono cioè vorrei essere più
forte ma non lo sono
lorenzo brusca celani non importanti in
una fiammata continua a 34 più nota un
breve in spite meno grassi grey fox
sembro ninja e tre o quattro fiammate
brevi né spreco meno a me non ho ricordo
grazie
sì o cantanti con la z è mappa dei video
e dove presso rizzo quella fare lì skip
pressurizzati gesù sia che debba andare
proprio linee non ciò la torcia accesa
non ho niente sono fermo
[Musica]
beh chi sta
l'altro noi stiamo volteggiando nello
spazio da quanto tempo esattamente sei
ore
[Musica]
esci da jesce veloce che sono
cominciato piano casa acustica la festa
così
ti pare che è caduta proprio lui non
doveva accadere
proprio lì dove devo andare
volevo lancia la pila questa la forza di
un ornitorinco morto
[Musica]
no
mi permetto
dovevo aspettare che si pressori zì kg
siamo a metà
75 bene cento pressurizzazione della
presa d'aria al cento per cento
complicato aggiunge la chiesa d'aria
l'ultimo step che mi rimane la salvezza
raga
[Musica]
chiudi la porta gioca a gesù
maronna mia che ansia di vivere vigna
pia tutta la saluta veloce mi chiedo
mettermi a tutte in tempo sono stati che
culo sevastopol a quello dovrebbe essere
alieno dovrebbe non esserci più
io sono rimasto un'ora in quella cabina
liquidi dovrei dovremmo essere
lontanissimi dalla navicella
[Musica]
se pensate che quello mi sono fatto per
tornare sulla ma non fa più rumore con
la fila maletti utilizzano magnete lo
chiudi ci hai ragione tu
eccolo che ha sempre pensato
[Musica]
gesù chris dyer incredibile
ci abbiamo messo una vita ce l'abbiamo
fatta
assurda st parte sta parte era veramente
un casino giuro gesù dai elevati statuto
a pang ul tima lance tra l'altro tra
l'altro quel tipo che mi ha sganciato
quindi quando mai il nome andiamo lì da
gli diamo fuoco che dite così no no ma è
una roba è mai venuta da me pensa sono
tornato io
la stazione è salva c'è di più
resta il fatto che si sta tornando al
dipartimento discuteremo lì i tuoi
metodi ma invece ragione sicuramente non
è che posso essere contento mi chiamava
spedito nello spazio roma un go lloyd e
vabbè vabbè www.eco discutiamo i suoi
metodi in questo momento che dici
potevate darmelo un po prima sto fucile
a pompa invece che adesso però va bene
anche così minchia rega che anzi asta
parte
ha tra l'altro questa dall'inizio ecco a
proposito poi vi ricordate dove stava il
corso del medikit qua sarà così ma
almeno prendevo il primo medikit intanto
trova un peso per salvare che dite
salviamo ma forse dovevo tornare
indietro
ma chissenefrega se andare avanti se
minchia che anzi asta parte veramente
regata no no e non ho salvato io quindi
cioè non è che mi fate fare tutto porca
vacca schifosa non fai in tempo a quel
tempo non fa in tempo non fa in tempo
non la molla ma la molla non ci credo
bon ton riuscito a salvare un proiettile
molto male va beh se la vi e forte su ci
aspetta un'altra mi è andata bene quindi
che non avevo salvato capito quindi ho
rischiato tantissimo
dov'è un salvataggio schifoso ecco lo
fate di salvare scusatemi non per questa
parte qua marca vacca let's go direi che
per oggi va bene così mammamia lega
quota play c'è ancora un botto di
raffredda in chiave si vede un sacco che
sono che sono influenzato sono bianco
cadaverico sono molto contento dall'hiv
di oggi molto bene direi basta
se volete farmi qualche domanda rimango
qua ancora due tre minuti e poi
saccheggio
grazie tasin grazie 90 79 per le nazioni
cosa ne pensi dei babbuini che si
grattano il sedere sono persone orribili
orribili orribile anche la mia influenza
abbiamo la stessa maglietta davvero ti
sei spaccato anche tu la maglietta
evidente perché avevo fame bravo il
finale te lo tieni per un'altra line ma
non penso che la prossima nave sia la
finale non lo so se come non basti ce ne
vogliono ancora due di live poi boh
lui sa quante domande rega perché al
giorno
mamma mia che sono presa dalla bella dai
sono proprio soddisfatto
gigi gigi vorrei farti i complimenti per
aver avuto per aver avuto la forza di
farla danni durante l'influenza grazie
in realtà
certo in realtà non è che se avessi
avuto proprio febbre sempre sarebbe
stato più difficile
buona notte l'ora con latte gaia grazie
mille ciao costa zero grazie alla
nazione vive da solo si mi aspetta
matematica ragazzi per chi a scuola
domani non vi invidio sono curioso di
vedere la tua scrivania ma guarda che
l'ho fatta vedere in un sacco di foto è
la maschera cometa faccio vedere di
riflesso ora di arrivare a riflesso se
vede con la mio fazzoletto sporco lo
vede riflesso nel mio fazzoletto sporco
[Musica]
caldo sarà la prossima live giovedì come
sempre ma la notte quella notte amici
controllo di fornet da 1 a 10 ma in un
odio four nights testa mi scredita io
non odio four nights iodio la gente che
mi dice a non si gioca musiano e devi
giocare cosa ha fatto in pratica se tua
fornite un gioco bello semplicemente la
gente è iniziata a rompermi le palle su
come giocare allora ho smesso di farlo
ma non odio fornai infatti il titolo io
perché odio fornito odio tra virgolette
perché non è che odio forni riporterà il
che hip hop il keep hope non è un gioco
comunque non penso
porti under the hill ma ai kent anything
ricordati di mettere a posto il bot
bravo bravo adesso lo faccio non mi
ricordo come si fa però qualche modo
peggio resta sul canada live come sempre
tutte le live sono sul canale ragazzuoli
io col mio fazzoletto vi lascio grazie
per aver seguito la live siete stati
società quando un bacino come servire
piaciuto lasciare un commento
è un bel mi piace anche vari social come
nei video da una descrizione dove ho
messo il telecomando politici graziato
ecco quattro signori se non servirsi di
schiavi grazie per aver seguito live
era come sempre ci vediamo l'anno
prossimo visto dai ragazzi